drivers aren't the only ones changing
their travel plans because of rising
fuel prices
American Airlines warns that fares are
likely to increase to offset a nearly 26
percent jump in its fuel bill for the
first three months of this year some
airlines are working to make their
planes lighter to save money Kris Van
Cleave went on board United Airlines new
project in Houston long before this
Boeing 787 left the gate a team at
United Airlines was focused on making it
and their entire 750 plane fleet as
light as possible every little bit
counts even on a plane that weighs more
than 250,000 pounds Erin stache leads
that team anytime we can reduce even an
ounce of weight that means we burn less
fuel to fly to that destination even an
ounce matters even an ounce because if
you are multiplying that across the
thousands of seats and the thousands of
flights we have that ounce adds up and
multiplies very quickly that one ounce
lighter magazine saves nearly 300
thousand dollars a year United rethought
everything about its aircraft from what
stocked in the galley to redesigning
bathrooms and yes some of those did get
smaller to newer lighter seats many
without heavy video monitors this card
is kind of heavy mm-hmm
this one is noticeably lighter these new
beverage carts are 27 pounds that's
about half the weight of the old
50-pound carts these new cargo
containers are about 80 pounds lighter
which will save 2 million gallons of
fuel a year and stopping duty-free sales
saved United another 1.4 million gallons
that's a combined savings of about 7
million dollars all of these efforts
what does that mean as a bottom line for
the airline how much fuel does that save
you we've improved our efficiency over
30% that's through the changes that
we're making on the interior of the
cabin the changes that we're doing on
the exterior of the aircraft as well as
a new aircraft that we're purchasing it
changes that have saved United well over
two billion dollars other airlines are
also pinching pounds Southwest is
rolling out slimline seats in its new
737 max fleet they're lighter and take
up less space the low fare carrier saved
148 thousand gallons of fuel by changing
how its
the galleys and dropping glass bottles
for cans giving pilots tablets instead
of paper manuals saves 80 pounds of
flight that doesn't sound like much but
it translates to nearly five hundred and
seventy six thousand gallons of fuel a
year that's more than a million dollars
in savings annually
JetBlue saving weight with its new
in-flight entertainment system it'll
feature lighter components that take up
less storage space spirit went with
lighter seats and this smaller tray
table that also allows more rows of
seats to fit on boards it all gets down
to weight CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg doing all this doesn't make
the planes any faster and it certainly
doesn't make them any more comfortable
in fact it's just about fuel efficiency
and fuel savings and that just gets back
to the airlines there's no real
passenger benefit but United says it's
more than just dollars United alone uses
almost four billion gallons so anytime
we can reduce our fuel use that goes to
write to our bottom line from an
environmental perspective which is
reducing our emissions it's reducing our
carbon footprint fuel is basically 99%
of an airline's carbon footprint the 737
max is 14% more fuel-efficient than its
predecessors in part because of this
thing on the end of the wing it's called
a winglet it reduces drag for the plane
burns less fuel and later this summer
the airline plans to completely strip
down one of its planes looking for
anywhere else it can save weight and
thus fuel for CBS this morning Kris Van
Cleave Houston wow they're gonna say
gotta leave your iPad behind that extra
weight